her name is Salwa she's 5 years old and
weighs just three and a half kilograms
in the middle of the world's worst
humanitarian disaster
now hit by coronavirus in a crisis of
funding - this is what childhood looks
like our cameraman found Salwa with her
parents and siblings in a mud hut that
is the family's third home in their
short life became better words would ask
me wonderful Sena what adorable girl
Tanya what is actually what kind it is
huh
what a lady in adorable show a hugger
bubbly as Ibrahim talks she lies
motionless next to him she is still
alive but it's a wonder how I say yeah
say yeah in the corner when no harm
could hire in in how serene we were
happy preview a man like that happening
in a place where there is next to no
health care a cameraman in his car is
also a lifeline and an ambulance the
journey to the nearest clinic is about
20 miles the front line of this war is
closer
inside she's measured a healthy child's
reading would be in the green there's
yellow then red six centimeters and
she's weighed 3.6 kilos an average
five-year-old should be seventeen two
million children under the age of five
are believed to be malnourished here of
them about 325,000 have severe acute
malnutrition they may survive if they
make it to one of the few functioning
hospitals but even then like nearly half
the children in Yemen
they'll be stunted the impact on their
development is already irreparable the
mark low cork is the UN's humanitarian
chief millions of people simply don't
have an income or any source of money to
buy the food and that's why the UN
having but we can only do that to the
extent that we have the money if we
don't have the money this is the
backdrop to the latest shift in this
country's misery
last month Sky News revealed the extent
of the corona virus outbreak in Yemen
official estimates suggest that more
than 1 million people may have
contracted the disease but this is only
half the problem a global recession
means a massive cut by donors aid
projects halted there is no bed in a
local hospital for Salwa back at their
home her mother Aisha gives us some
fruit juice when she has it and sugar
when she doesn't it helps her to sleep
honey that is a situation is really very
difficult she says I wish that she could
get dressed and I could see her playing
Eliana the world has a simple
straightforward choice
it can either resume funding of the aid
operation and save millions of lives or
it can watch as the country simply falls
off the cliff her siblings are doing a
little better that is the
unpredictability of malnutrition none of
the children is getting adequate food
but for them it's not yet acute for
salva though the truth is it may be too
late
mark stone Sky News